today's episode is sponsored by blinkist
the app that lets you
read or listen to an entire nonfiction
book
in just 15 minutes you can try blinkist
totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
below this video
we have just eight days to go until the
2020 election
and the election is essentially a baked
cake at this point in time with just
days remaining
the two candidates couldn't be more
different the number of
undecideds is relatively small we know
the top issues to voters or coronavirus
the economy
and the race related protests that we've
seen over the last several months
followed by
health care and a number of other
different issues and i do think it's
important just to remember that this is
a unique election
the circumstances are particularly
different we're in the middle of a
hundred year pandemic we've got the most
incompetent president
that we've ever had and that there are
really important
issues that neither candidate is talking
about
and that are rarely talked about in many
presidential elections
but we need to remember this large
swath of important issues that if joe
biden were to win
we are going to need to get right back
to shining a spotlight on now the point
of doing this segment is not to attack
either candidate per se it is a reminder
about
circumstances this is not about who we
should vote for
obviously for the sake of humanity and
the future of the country
we must vote for joe biden but all of
that being said
there has been no substantive discussion
about as an example labor unions
and the democratization of the workplace
there's been no substantive discussion
about
tech monopolies outside of donald trump
complaining about how
twitter and google treat him unfairly no
discussion of the massive change to our
economy that has happened and is
happening which means quite simply
that a ton of those manufacturing jobs
are never coming back because they don't
exist
these aren't trivial things and they go
to the core
of how our country has changed and
potentially could change depending on
who we elect
and the reason it's crucial that we talk
about this
is that someday the pandemic will be
over someday
hopefully there will be a reasonable
person in the oval office again
hopefully the latter will happen in
january
and we're going to need to be ready to
get back to the serious work
on issues that are sort of higher on
maslow's
hierarchy of needs for lack of a better
term i'll get back to that idea but
let's go through the issues
back in 2016 i talked about this and
it's happening again which is that
neither candidate will just come out and
say a lot of the manufacturing jobs are
never coming back
many of the jobs just don't exist
anymore because they've been replaced by
technology
others aren't going to come back unless
we
change our economy so drastically that
labor is as cheap here as it is in
bangladesh and china and other countries
and of course
our economy is based on the labor being
cheaper there than here
so if we don't reorganize the economy
and keep pretending that it's just a
battle over who can bring those jobs
back
we're in a fantasy world that has to be
dealt with neither trump nor hillary
would say it in 2016. they would both
say
i'll bring the jobs back no i'll bring
the jobs back because it's not
politically advantageous to admit
many of the jobs aren't coming back no
matter who we elect if you say it your
opponent says that's the defeatist
attitude
and it's happening again this election
until we recognize and admit that
we won't move on in terms of figuring
out okay
given that many of those jobs aren't
coming back how do we organize structure
and supplement our economy biden has
done a little bit of it by saying
this isn't about saving jobs in a dying
industry like coal
it's about creating new industries
altogether like green energy jobs
but both candidates are very lacking on
that issue
labor unions and democratizing the
workplace
neither candidate is saying a word about
it other than claiming
i have the support of the unions joe
biden
has actually been okay on this issue at
times in his career
big amtrak guy which is a union
represented organization
but looking at the industries where
workers are most vulnerable and figuring
out how do we increase union
representation
how do we change the fundamental
dynamics of the relationships between
corporations and workers
to be more like the countries that don't
need as strong of a union presence
because they've dealt with the issues
that unions are often there to
to deal with talking about employee
representation on company boards dealing
with
stock repurchasing which just helps
shareholders and executives
if this all sounds weird it's because
neither can that it talks about it for a
combination of reasons
trump doesn't talk about it because he
doesn't support any of this stuff
biden again may support some of it his
historical views on amtrak suggest that
he does
but he's not talking about it maybe
because we have a five or
five alarm fire when it comes to
coronavirus in the economy
maybe it's because he's decided it's not
to his advantage but either way
we have to get back to that once sanity
returns and then number three
tech monopolies elizabeth warren and
bernie sanders
did talk about it andrew yang talked
about it with regard to our data
but we're not hearing about it from
trump nor biden trump
sort of will dance around it when he's
mad at tech companies which he says are
far left
and are being unfair to him it's totally
self-serving it's not
actually being dealt with as an issue
and joe biden's not really talking about
it either in a prominent way
and by the way the debate moderators
haven't brought up these issues either
so we we can say that there's a lot of
blame to go around here so the point is
not to say that i have any doubt about
who we should vote for
on tuesday or or now if you're voting
now
it's obviously joe biden and to some
degree we have an emergency
like coronavirus and so it's natural
that some of these issues would fall
back
if we go to maslow's hierarchy of needs
if our basic needs of safety security
and health aren't met
it's less likely we're going to get into
tech monopolies and i understand that
but we must remember that there are
major political issues
missing from the campaign right now we
can say they're missing because of
coronavirus
we can say they're missing because trump
is such a dumpster fire that until he's
removed we can't deal with them
and that's fine but we need a plan
for when we get the ball back as i've
been saying biden winning is getting the
ball back we're not scoring points
we're just getting the opportunity to
play offense again we need to be ready
to do it particularly since there may be
a two-year window of senate and house
control
which will then be be replaced by
republicans taking control back of
either or both
the house and senate so very important
that we bear this in mind
okay we now have just one week and one
day from the election
three different models to look at every
model says the same thing
and people emailed me over the weekend
saying david you've got to comment on
these models because
is there any case to be made for
anything other than biden
crushing trump so let's look at the
models and yes
every single one of these says joe
biden's doing really well the first
model is the 538 model which currently
says that joe biden
has an 87 percent chance to win while
trump has a 12 percent chance to win
with a 1 chance that neither candidate
gets to 270
electoral votes this means if you run
100 simulations with the current
polling inputs and you adjust for margin
for error
biden would win in 87 simulations and
trump would win in 12.
if you look at the electoral vote
projections of 538
joe biden they believe will end up with
345 electoral votes
trump with not even 200. that would be a
very solid win for joe
and then lastly looking at popular vote
predictions 538 estimates
that biden will win about 53 of the
popular vote
with a roughly eight point margin that
would be the largest popular vote
victory
in a very long time and then if you look
at the model from the economist the
economist's estimate is that joe biden
has a 95 percent chance to win
uh the electoral vote in terms of the
popular vote the economist says biden
has a greater than
99 chance of winning the popular vote
and uh cites some popular or rather
electoral vote numbers
which uh give a possibility that trump
wins
but overwhelmingly skewed to joe biden
in terms of the electoral college as far
as their best
guess on electoral numbers it's not a
range here but a best guess
the economist believes that it will be
biden 352
and trump 186 which also would be a
huge win for uh for joe biden
and then lastly the in terms of the
electoral vote
trends the economist has seen biden's
expected electoral votes rising for the
last roughly two months
since the start of september and then
we've got the princeton model
run by sam wang the estimate is biden
360 electoral votes with the senate
going to democrats 52 to 48
and democrats keeping control of the
house so what's the counter to all this
because it all just looks so great right
record early voting more democrats than
republicans in some states it just looks
great well
the counterpoints are number one none of
this can account for voter suppression
and that could be a big factor period
don't even need to say more
that's just huge by itself number two
the polling looking at people who have
not yet voted but are likely to vote
is overwhelmingly in favor of trump in
some of these battleground states
suggesting that yes the early voting
may well favor biden in some of these
key states
but the people who will vote on election
day
may heavily favor donald trump so what
can we do
all we can do is vote you know it i know
it
we've got eight days to go let me know
your voting plan
i'm on twitter deepakman and we will
have much more on this uh coming up a
little bit later in the show
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
non-fiction book
in just 15 minutes i recently read a
brief history of time of course by the
great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different non-fiction
categories and a subscription
is only about eight bucks a month and
you get the entire
library but you can try it totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
we now have seen the full 60 minute
interview out of which donald trump
abruptly walked last week and it's as
embarrassing as it is hilarious it's as
dystopian as it is preposterous and
we're going to look at it
this is the interview that took place a
few days ago last week leslie
stahl was interviewing donald trump at
the white house for last uh last night
60 minutes episode
and trump abruptly walked out early
threatened to release an
uncut version of the interview and did
so proving nothing other than
he's a [ __ ] now we have a full proper
airing from 60 minutes and i want to get
right into it
in this first clip donald trump just
whines there's no other way to say it he
whines like he's an underprivileged
oppressed person rather than the most
powerful person in the world he whines
about how joe biden
doesn't get interview questions that
trump wants him to get and then
this is really wild trump brings up
obama spied on me
and you don't talk about it leslie and
leslie stahl explains we can't air stuff
that we
can't find evidence for and it gets ugly
and it gets hilarious i wish you would
interview joe biden like you interview
me
it would be so good you know what you
like this i thought i thought you i
don't mind it i don't mind but when i
watch him
walk out of his store and he's walking
with a
ice cream and the question the media
asks him what kind of ice cream what
flavor ice cream do you have
and he's in the midst of a scandal he's
not and he's taking
course he is leslie come on of course he
is it's the biggest
second biggest scandal the biggest
scandal was when they spied on my
campaign
they spied on my career there's no real
evidence of that of course there is it's
all over the place
leslie they spied on my campaign and
they get caught can i say something
you know this is 60 minutes and we can't
put on things we can't very well put it
on because it's bad for biting we can't
put on things we can't verify
leslie they spied on my campaign well we
can't very well i'm totally verified
no it's been just go down and get the
papers
they spied on my campaign they got
caught no and then they went much
further than that and they got caught
and you will see that leslie and you
know that but you just don't want to put
it over here
as a matter of fact i don't know that
okay now what i wish
leslie stahl would have asked is mr
president
sir as he likes to say i will look into
this
obama biden crime if you can tell me
what law you believe was broken what
crime was actually committed here
because trump doesn't know
trump is lost in his own conspiracy
theory we've seen it before when he's
actually asked
what are you alleging he says come on
you know what it is unless you're part
of the fake news covering it up
pathetic trump and remember trump thinks
this interview makes him look good
that's one of the most delusional parts
of this trump then asked whether
insulting people on
twitter is a good idea trump says it is
but the most notable thing here is trump
complains more
that leslie stahl's questions are
inappropriate and again complains
about the questions given to joe biden
and then he just gets up and leaves
do you think that your tweets
and your name calling are turning people
off
no i think i wouldn't be here if i
didn't have social media but the media
is fake
and frankly if i didn't have social
media
i'd have no way of getting out my voice
do you know what you told me
a long time ago when i asked why you
keep saying fake
media yeah you said to me i say that
because i need to dis uh discredit you
so that when you say negative things
about me no one will believe i don't
have to discredit you
but that's what you discredited yourself
you know
i didn't want to have this kind of anger
she did
no i didn't no i didn't well then you
brought up a lot of subjects
well i said i'm gonna ask you tough
questions they were inappropriately
brought up
right from the beginning no your first
question was this is
going to be tough questions you don't
ask joe biden
i saw your interview with joe the
interviewer i never did a joke
i was a joke the interview 60 minutes
i see joe biden giving softball after
softball
i've seen all of his interviews he's
never been asked a question that's hard
okay but
forget him for a minute no but your
president your president
excuse me leslie you started with me
your first statement was
are you ready for tough questions are
you that's no way to talk
there's no way to talk leslie at this
point
one of our producers interrupted to
advise about the time remaining in the
interview
i think we have enough of an interview
here hope okay that's enough
let's go let's go uh
let's go meet for two seconds okay
thanks i'll see you in a little while
thanks
be careful
can you imagine a more whiny president
wine wine wine and then i think
uh uh we have enough he says i think we
have enough buh-bye
here's the moment where trump actually
does the walking out and press secretary
kelly mckennony comes in
with that oversized book and it's it's
just total cringe i would be ashamed to
be kaylee mckennany
she deserves never to work again after
this nightmare is over there's actually
a long list of people associated with
this clown
that deserve to never work again but
check i mean this is just if you're
allergic to cringe
i would probably turn away at this point
we were scheduled to take a walk with
the president
around the white house grounds i've got
a lot of questions i didn't ask
while we waited to see if the president
was coming back
his press secretary kaylee mcaney came
in
with a hand delivery leslie the
president wanted me to deliver his
health care plan it's a little heavy
oh my god this is his healthcare plan
yes okay
koat thank you you're welcome and uh the
vice president will be with you shortly
okay and the president's not coming back
uh the president's giving me a lot of
time
it was heavy filled with executive
orders
congressional initiatives but no
comprehensive health plan
so not all the pages were blank there
was actually some stuff in there
meaningless stuff and as leslie stall
points out nothing in there about
trump's supposedly forthcoming
healthcare plan trump again raises this
idea
that covet cases are rising merely
because of more testing he's sticking
with that
four years ago you were behind in the
polls as you are now
and you pulled it out but this time you
have kind of a double
migraine you have unemployment claims
going up
you have coveted cases going up
i mean it's like the gods have suddenly
decided decided to conspire against i
really sort of don't know i think well
what about a job
sir excuse me cases are up in about 40
states you know why cases are up also
because we do more testing the fake news
media loves to say cases are up
the fact is we've done a very very good
job we have done
that's right because we're doing so much
testing there is
increased testing but according to the
covet tracking project
that doesn't account for all of the rise
in new cases
sweeping the country or the 40 increase
in hospitalizations
in the past month understand that this
is an
easily debunkable lie testing is up 4
over the last week cases are up 21 if
you want to make the case
that cases are only up because testing
is up
if you test 10 percent more and find 10
more cases you might be able to make
that argument you might be able to make
the argument that
this is roughly the number of cases that
was there all along we're just testing
more people and
making more of those cases official but
when you test four percent more
and cases go up 21 and hospitalizations
are up
you understand that it's a lie this is
an existential threat this man is an
existential
threat that must be removed and he's
lying to you every day whether he
understands the math of it
probably not but he is lying every day
and then lastly
on trump before we move to one pence
clip
leslie stahl good for her
calls out trump on the health care plan
that he's been promising for months
and trump says we're going to announce
it very very soon
you promised that there was going to be
a new health package
a healthcare plan yeah um you said that
it was going to be great
you said it's ready it's going to be
ready it'll be here in two weeks
it's going to be like nothing you've
ever seen before and of course we
haven't seen it
so why didn't you develop a health plan
it is developed
it is fully developed it's going to be
announced very soon
when we see what happens with obamacare
if
the supreme court ends this obamacare
um well we're gonna have to see what
happens i think i i hope that they end
it
it'll be so good of them and if they end
up people with pre-existing conditions
will be stranded
and that's just a fact it's wrong it's
wrong
a new plan will happen but we won't do
anything
will and is we won't do anything and no
plan
unless we have pre-existing conditions
covered of course at this point i don't
know that anybody believes that this
plan
actually exists remember that in august
donald trump said to cr
there's video of trump promising it in
2017 and 2018 and 2019. but more
recently in august trump said during
that
bizarre interview with chris wallace we
are going to sign a new health care bill
into law in two weeks
and of course it's almost november at
this point
it probably doesn't exist here is leslie
stahl
after trump walked out asking vice
president mike pence
why did donald trump end his interview
early pence just has no idea how to
respond take a look
while our interview with the president
did not go forward
the one scheduled with the vice
president did
so what just happened with the president
leslie president trump is a man who
speaks his mind
i think it's one of the great strengths
that he's had but he was president of
the united states is that the american
people always know where they stand
and he's always ready and the american
people know that
in this time it's it's it's less about
the
back and forth with the media and it's
it's really more about how we bring this
country all the way back
what why did trump leave mr vice
president the president is always ready
leslie the president is always ready
an embarrassment but remember trump
as a narcissist probably can't even
acknowledge or comprehend that this was
an embarrassment and in fact
trump thought the raw uncut video made
him look good
and he released it a few days ago i do
think
despite donald trump's weaponized
narcissism
and inability to feel shame i do think
if he loses to biden the way he might
lose if we all get out and vote and the
votes are counted properly
i actually do think trump may be ashamed
by by losing to joe biden badly because
he's alluded to it he said can you
imagine if i lost to this guy
can you imagine if i lost to this worst
candidate or whatever it is that he says
i think that that will actually bring
shame to donald trump
just a bonus primary reason to vote
biden
is to start righting the ship of the
united states
very far down the list but interesting
nonetheless is donald trump actually
being ashamed of being brutally defeated
by joe biden let's make it happen
there are growing concerns among anyone
who's seen recent video of the president
that donald trump is having a major
problem communicating coherently
i know that that's been a problem for
years but that it's happening
even more right now trump has been doing
rallies at a very high rate sometimes
three rallies in different states in one
day and the things coming out of his
mouth
have gone from factually wrong to
straight up unintelligible one such
rally over the weekend was in lumberton
north carolina on saturday
an important state where joe biden has a
very
small lead right now in the latest polls
could go either way
and here is donald trump talking about i
guess the wall
with mexico is the topic but i i am
issuing a challenge to you what on earth
is donald trump saying here
[Applause]
and mexico is paying for the wall they'd
like to have you say no no
once it was complete once they knew the
wall oh and we can't talk about the wall
anymore
then they said ah oh listen but
mexico's not paying for it no they are
paying for it so now they're totally
they don't know what the hell to do just
one of those things they don't know what
to do
mexico is going to pay for the wall when
it's built
but because it's already built you don't
have to say it anymore
but they did pay for it but of course in
reality it's not been built
what is he talking about i chat please
let me know what exactly is donald trump
saying here
another strange moment at a rally
saturday in ohio
trump saying joe biden draws flies which
is
it's it's weird because number one the
most notable moment from the vice
presidential debate
was when a fly literally landed on mike
pence not not figuratively
there's some you know religious
metaphors about flies landing on you
that don't mean much to me
a fly literally landed on mike pence and
then number two as you'll see here
trump actually had a fly on him during
this rally you can't write this stuff
you don't want sleepy joe to be your
president you know he draws flies he's
not drawing anybody
of all of this stuff they're tired of
such negative hey by the way i had it
here i am i mean you know
it used to be that if you had it
you were immune for life right for life
how strange a time are we living in not
only that trump is saying
biden draws flies but that during his
weekend rallies
he also had a fly on him it's
inconceivable it almost is beyond
if this was a screenplay you would say
it's not it's too it's too out there
it's too
cliche we can't do it it's not
believable remember last week that
donald trump cut a rally short because
it was too cold for him
this time complaining that it's too hot
and he's going to have to cut it short
again
is that sun hot or what
[Music]
i'm going to be a lobster do you mind if
i cut this one at about one third
because i'm gonna be one
hell of a sunburned person
[Applause]
[Music]
does anybody have some sun protection
for your president please
this is beautiful oh man
i said to my kids stay out of the sun
always use sunblock
hey always use sunblock and here i am
that's really brilliant
and then the president claiming that joe
biden is the candidate of
needless death which again it's just
projection biden is a candidate of
endless war and deedless death
of course needless death it's you know
donald needless death trump it might as
well be the guy's middle name
he uh due to his completely
failed coronavirus response numerous
respected studies pointing out many
deaths
that were not necessary needless death
in this next clip donald trump seems to
think that this is just weird
trump seems to think the paris climate
accords are in some way specific
to paris it's really weird like he says
look at how paris is doing and we're not
in the paris accord we don't feel like
spending trillions of dollars in
destroying our businesses
okay how's it doing for paris not so
well
very strange donald trump might be
shocked to know that the camp david
accords were not actually about
circumstances at camp david
and then as a final touch at the rally
and who knows where this one even
was at this point i can't keep it
straight was this florida north carolina
uh ohio i don't know a guy throughout
the event repeatedly flashing a white
power
sign with his right hand right behind
trump
was noticed right away by people
watching the rally so
certainly anybody watching this stuff
has to understand
the behavior is becoming increasingly
erratic
trump continuing to launch brutal
assaults on the english language
but also on common decency and also on
democracy
and now the latest is the white house
seems to have
formally given up on controlling the
pandemic i want to talk about that next
so donald trump's chief of staff mark
meadows
horrible guy just a terrible person went
on cnn yesterday
was interviewed by jake tapper and
straight up said we're not going to
control the pandemic
all hell has broken loose although if
you've been paying attention
we're eight or nine months in of course
they're not going to control the
pandemic that's obvious at this point
you just wouldn't imagine that mark
meadows would straight up say it
check out this is uh we call them the
maskless wonder mark meadows because
he's known for
walking around every trump rally with no
mask hugging people touching people
high-fiving people
he says we're not going to control the
pandemic so here's what we have to do
we're not going to control the pandemic
we are going to control the fact that we
get uh vaccines therapeutics and other
mitigations what are we going to do
because it is a contagious virus just
like the food
but why not make efforts to contain it
well we are making efforts to contain it
by running all over the country not
wearing a mask
that's what the vice president back and
forth let me just say this
is what we need to do is make sure that
we have
the proper mitigation factors whether
it's therapies or vaccines or
treatments now of course we don't have
those things that mark meadows says we
should have
but also mark meadows is wrong it can be
contained look at the places that have
contained it taiwan
south korea japan slovakia
bangladesh with a very low death rate
australia of course with a very low
death rate
we know it can be done in countries of
varied geographical size
and varied population size because
they've
done it listen to jake tapper here as we
continue
having to treat mark meadows like a
little kid to make sure that people
don't die from this
but to suggest that we're going to
actually quarantine
all of america and knock down our
insanely well that they are joe biden's
saying that he says lock everybody down
we're going to have
we're going to have a dark we're going
to have a dark winter we're going to
have a darkness that's what health
officials say
that's what health officials say that
it's going to get worse
since friday and saturday then
the health officials did not say dark
winter those were joe biden's word
when we look at
when we look when we look at the number
of cases increasing
what we have to do is make sure that we
fight it with therapeutics and vaccines
take proper medication factors in terms
of social distancing
and mass when we can so mark meadows
there
again listing things we should do
that they are not doing but again
anybody
looking at the trend lines sees a dark
winter coming look at the chart of cases
in the united states
i'll describe it i've marked the first
two spikes
and look at the trend line we have the
first red arrow here
points to spike number one where we got
the 35 000 cases a day then the numbers
backed off a little bit
the second arrow is spike number two in
july
75 000 cases a day and now we already
had a record
eighty one thousand and seventy nine
thousand cases per day on friday
and saturday and the trend line is going
to the moon
if this were a stock chart of a stock
you owned
you'd be getting ready to make a ton of
money because it looks like it's going
to the moon
sadly this is not a stock chart this is
coronavirus cases
next mark meadows tries to go after joe
biden hilariously
and when we when we look at this what
we're we're going to defeat it jake
because what we are we're americans we
do that and this president is leading
while joe biden
is sitting there suggesting that we're
going to mandate president is holding
rallies all right that's all over the
country that's correct
we're leaving no masks required no
we have already been according to health
officials
contact tracing there have already been
cases of individuals
in minnesota and in washington dc
and in oklahoma that got the virus at
these trump rallies
that dr fauci himself called a super
spreader
imagine saying biden is the problem
because he wants a mass
mandate which by the way is not
something a president can do
unilaterally
this often isn't discussed but a
presidential mass mandate
but by everything i've read from left
and right wing constitutional scholars
a presidential mask mandate would be one
of two things either the president
asks all 50 governors to do a mask
mandate in which state it's states
rights in which case it states rights
it's 50 governors saying let's do this
or congress would have to pass something
um through the uh ability of the federal
government to regulate
commerce in states those are the two
ways so the idea of a unilateral
presidential mass
mandate is really a fantasy idea quite
frankly
understand what it really means but
again the fact that people are having
this
argument we have a situation where
people are arguing about the freedom
to give the virus to other people that's
essentially what it is
freedom freedom to do whatever the hell
i want regardless of the consequences
and then they have to go to what joe
biden might do
after the chief of staff says we're not
going to control the virus
this should be an abide in ad
immediately mark meadows plainly saying
we're not going to control the pandemic
we know mark
we know we're gonna take a quick break
make sure you're following us on
instagram at david pakman show see what
i was up to this weekend follow me on
instagram
at david.pacman the david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way
is through membership which includes the
world famous bonus show as well as
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show
just for members sign up today at
joinpackman.com
coupon code saves you 40 vote soon 18.
[Music]
welcome back to the david pakman show
congresswoman debbie mccarsell powell
represents
florida's 26th district she joins me
today
uh congresswoman thanks for being on i
really appreciate your time
thank you for having me david the
florida vote
is very very interesting florida as a
state
may well determine who wins the
presidential election joe biden or
donald trump
and then within florida your district
may actually signal the way that the
state goes it's a very interesting
district as as you've mentioned
uh in other conversations we've had
nearly 70 percent
latino voters uh talk a little bit about
the dynamics there in florida what are
the most important issues to floridians
well first let me say that you're
absolutely correct i think that the
state of florida
is going to be one of the most important
states in this election the road to the
white house
begins in florida and yes it starts in
florida's 26th district
the top issue here has been and
continues to be
healthcare healthcare access i represent
an area where
um 70 of the people that live in my
district are
latinos hispanic from the hispanic
community very diverse
ecuadorians colombians argentinians
mexicans
many of them are cuban americans and for
them
during this pandemic this pandemic has
hit us very hard here in miami-dade
county we became the epicenter of the
of covid during the summer and it's
because of failed leadership
locally and at the state level and many
people lost their jobs
they didn't have access to quality
health care and the stakes of this
election have become even higher now
that the senate is trying to
push for that nomination to the supreme
court the supreme court as you know is
going to be hearing
the lawsuit to repeal the affordable
care act and in my district
david we have the second largest number
of people that get their health care
through the aca
300 000 individuals in my district have
pre-existing conditions
so if the aca is repealed you would see
millions of americans losing their
health coverage and so many here in my
district that would lose that
and i can tell you that the energy in
south florida
it has gone up significantly in the past
two months
people are out there they're engaged
there are so many grassroots movements
uh going on in south florida they are
coming out for me
they're coming out for biden they
understand what's what's at stake at
this election
and uh because of their care because
they know who's going to protect their
care
i think that the energy has really gone
way above what anybody expected
within the american electorate
there are different groups that tend to
vote one way or the other and as a
general rule
three of the most left-leaning groups
are
jewish americans african-americans and
latino or hispanic americans generally
within that last group
americans tend to be the most
conservative and there seems to be this
kind of reflexive anti-castro thing that
that goes on and that we've seen
um can you address a little bit you know
your district is the perfect
place epicenter to see all of these
different groups as you mentioned and
their priorities and and
vote voting interests uh does does the
the perspective of the cuban-american
electorate
seem different this time around yeah and
you know there is a group of cuban
americans that are
very much in favor of donald trump and
that's because
there has been a lot of misinformation
spread about the democrats they are
instigating fear saying that um
you know accusing democrats of being
socialist which is completely false and
for cuban americans and for a lot of
people that have fled violent regimes in
latin america
this is scary and they've been using
that message to divide
to control that vote uh but i can tell
you that there's also a significant
group of cuban americans who are
100 behind joe biden they know that
donald trump
has been an ally of vladimir putin and
and let's
back up for a second vladimir putin is
propping up
the narco regime in venezuela the maduro
regime
they are propping up cuba they're one of
their top allies in cuba
and trump is standing right next to them
so um
cuban americans here in mary many latin
americans understand that the person
that they need to fear is donald trump
because we're seeing so many signs
of someone that's trying to grab onto
power who's uh
doing whatever he can going towards the
road of an
authoritarian regime so cuban americans
here
are now standing up and saying no we do
not
support donald trump we are with biden
there's a group called
cubanos combined but there's also
ecuatorianos combined venezuelans
and that's been a grassroots um
movement that has started really by all
the latin americans that are living down
here that have said
enough we're not going to follow these
eyes anymore so i'm i'm very optimistic
and excited to see what's happening here
in south florida so
should we be concerned about the safety
of vote by mail
what do you see as again taking into
consideration all of the different
reasons one might vote one way or the
other uh what what is your message to
people about how it is that they should
vote if they really want to feel good
about uh knowing feeling that their vote
is likely to be counted
what i tell everyone here is your vote
is still
going to be safe and secure do not let
anyone distract you or make you think
otherwise our six systems are secure we
have been conducting oversight along
with the fbi we have been in
communication with our supervisor of
elections here locally
so if you need to vote by mail because
of health conditions because you're not
here physically
mail that envelope today sign it seal it
mail it that's what we're saying just
send your ballot early
if you can vote early we start early
voting october 19th
and you you can do that securely as well
wear a mask use your hand sanitizer
but vote whatever the plan is for you to
vote
vote vote in the way that's safest for
you for your family
vote every vote counts david
in 2018 i had a colleague or one of the
candidates in texas
who lost her election by 900
votes gina ortiz from texas who i think
are welcome into congress
in 2020 900 votes every single vote
counts
again if you have your ballot mail it in
sign it
mail it in send it it's safe it's secure
if you can vote in person vote early
don't wait until november third we have
two weeks of early voting here in
miami-dade and in monroe county
we can change the direction of this
country
and i i have a lot of optimism because
so many young people are excited they're
engaged
they're telling their parents their
abuelos dios primos primas everyone
to come out and vote and and we're gonna
see that we're gonna see a huge turnout
in 2020.
so this this is speculative it's just
your opinion but when do you believe we
will know
the election results if we vote
decisively
in florida if we have a decisive win in
florida that's going to be a
huge indicator that joe biden will be
our next president if joe biden wins
florida of course
that's what i'm referring to um if
we don't know it could take weeks
and so my recommendation is let all of
us
expect that uh don't fret don't
don't get anxious about it let's count
every single vote that's our democracy
we can be patient if we've waited this
long we can wait a couple of more weeks
but my hope is that florida is so
decisive
for joe biden that that will be a pretty
clear indicator
of who's going to take the white house
in january yeah it's um
it's it's going to be a very very
interesting election extremely high
stakes
um congresswoman debbie mccarsell powell
representing florida's 26th
district uh thank you so much for your
time i really appreciate you joining me
today
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners
and one way to keep us going is through
patreon
where you can pledge as little as one
dollar per month
or as much as you want at patreon.com
slash david pakman show great perks and
benefits as well
read about them
the david pakman show at
so davidpakman.com are absolutely
furious with donald trump for spreading
the completely
bogus conspiracy theory that doctors are
inflating the number of coronavirus
deaths for profit and that that's why
our numbers are so bad
i'm gonna explain this to you and
explain the genesis of this donald trump
has said that
we only have high case numbers because
we test so much
and now he's saying that we only have
such high deaths despite claiming
they're low
because doctors make money by lying
about the cause of death
take a look at this clip and then we're
going to discuss it this is from one of
trump's
harebrained saturday corona rallies this
one
in waukesha wisconsin take a look you
know some countries they report
differently
if somebody's sick with a heart problem
and they die of covet
they say they die of a heart problem if
somebody's terminally ill with cancer
and they have covid we report them and
you know
doctors get more money in hospitals get
more money
think of this incentive so some
countries do it differently
if somebody is very sick with a bad
heart they die of covert
they don't get reported as covet so then
you wonder gee i wonder why their cases
are so low
this country and the reporting systems
are really not doing it right
if somebody has a really bad heart and
they're close to death
even if they're not but they have a very
bad heart and they get coveted
they put it down to covet other
countries put it down to a heart
so we have to be a we're going to start
looking at things because you know
they have things back they have things a
little bit backwards
they have things a little bit back joe
biden is made
seriously if you hear donald trump say
that and you like it
and you believe it and you clap how can
you be trusted to have any job i mean
really
short of some completely menial task
with no contact with other people how
can you
have a job that involves interacting
with people in any way
teaching kids being an accountant i mean
just about any job
how could you be trusted to do anything
if you believe
when trump says cause of death is being
forged
for doctors to profit there are 60
million of these people
my friends it is a living nightmare in
the united states but understand that
donald trump has become your crazy uncle
spreading fake news on facebook
this specific conspiracy theory is one
that
i don't know if it started on facebook
but it was popular on facebook for a
while it's been around since early in
the pandemic
stuff like if a doctor says you have
covid they get an extra
thousand dollars if you die of it now i
do actually want to explain
where this comes from where it started
so that you're equipped to deal with it
as many of you know hospitals are paid
based on
diagnosis and treatment what do they
diagnose and what do they treat what do
they do to a patient
medicare so again we're talking about
only people of medicare age
medicare pays hospitals reimburses
hospitals
20 percent more for coronavirus patients
relative to my guess is a
non-coronavirus sort of like flu
admission because people of medicare age
on average
um require more treatment
and coronavirus on average has certain
protocols that cost more money
right so so you would it makes sense
that
if on average coronavirus is multiple
times more deadly than the flu
and on average older folks are more
likely to have a serious case than
younger folks it would make sense
that when medicare age people are
admitted to a hospital for coronavirus
there's going to be more treatment
provided and that costs more money in
the system that we have that would lead
to a higher reimbursement
now the conspiracy first of all there is
no evidence that hospitals
are fraudulently saying people have
coronavirus when they don't in order to
pad their revenue
that would be extremely serious
insurance fraud
but most importantly even like actually
think about it
a patient dying has no impact on revenue
there is no reason to lie
because trump is talking about cause of
death there's no reason to lie about
cause of death
and of course it would be hugely immoral
and doctors groups are furious that
donald trump is suggesting it rob
davidson
is an emergency room doctor who's part
of the committee to protect medicare
he said quote as a doctor this is such
an insult we report deaths how they
occur
if you did your damn job we wouldn't be
reporting
so many covet 19 deaths about 130
000 fewer according to a columbia
university study
this is a very common thing on the right
everything's fake
it's a smoke screen climate change is
fake
coveted deaths are fake and then when
they explain
why it's money someone is lying for
money
which is what they would do this is the
incredible projection that is here
when they don't want to accept a
scientific reality
they assume someone must be lying in
order to make money for themselves
and it's a big peak behind the curtain
for trump he must think
everyone on earth must be as terrible a
person as he is and so
if he would lie for personal gain the
doctors must also be lying for personal
gain
and by the way i don't even know if if
we need to do this
the virus as a way to make hospitals
money
hospitals are getting crushed during
coronavirus hospitals make money
with necessary but not urgent surgeries
hip replacements
knee scopes so on and so forth
those are all down dramatically during
the pandemic so the idea that the virus
is a hoax
generated to make money for the medical
industry is absurd because when you look
at the q2
gdp decline the leading declining
industry was the health care industry
this has been
terrible for the medical field
health care has been decimated by the
virus er visits are down
outpatient visits down surgeries down
shortened long-term care
prevented from prohibited from admitting
people for for months
during this huge increase in ppe costs
for the hospitals
even though they have fewer patients
it's been bad it doesn't make any sense
we must end this insanity barack obama's
trying to help end it and i want to talk
about that a little bit
it has been a pleasure to watch these
recent barack obama rallies
for joe biden socially distanced
drive-in rallies in various parts of the
country
and part of the entertainment is that
trump gets so triggered by it
on one hand it's good to have a reminder
of what it's like to have a president
who speaks
incomplete sentences can articulate an
idea with a beginning middle and an end
but trump's triggering has been
delightful
here's barack obama in miami saying
we can't just say it's okay for a
president to lie
constantly we can't just say oh it's
fine if if a president lies
50 times a day no
barack obama going on to say even
florida man the ubiquitous florida man
wouldn't do this stuff
why are we accepting it from the
president of the united states
florida man wouldn't even do this stuff
why are we accepting it from the
president of the united states
barack obama just laughing off the wacky
claim from trump that he's been been the
best
president for black folks since abe
lincoln and
you know he he loves talking about black
unemployment
says he's the best president for black
folks since abe lincoln
what and then this one i just love
referring to the 60 minutes interview
uh with leslie stahl barack obama
acute accurately uh points out the acute
problem with a president not even being
able to sit through
a tough interview and let me say i've
run for president miami so
i i just want you to know it's it's a
good idea to have an answer to this
question
it's a good idea if you're running for
reelection to say
here's what i want to accomplish what
did trump say
he got mad and walked out of the
interview
he thought the questions were too tough
too tough miami listen if he can't
answer
a tough question like what would you
like to do in your second term
then it's our job to make sure he
doesn't get a second term
and that's why over the next 10 days
we got to work hard to elect joe biden
and kamala
harris the next president and vice
president of the united states
just very well done there by barack
obama uh one more clip for you
and i understand the president's coming
to florida today
you think he's hard at work coming up
with a plan to get us out of this mess
well i don't know because i know he's
had a tough week
everybody has been very unfair
to donald trump this week so again trump
hugely triggered by this tweeting out of
control
starting to tweet as barack obama was
doing these events for joe biden
nobody's showing up for obama's
hate-laced
speeches 47 people no energy
but still better than joe retweeting
nonsense about joe biden and barack
obama killing the coal industry
as if that's a bad thing it's not true
but as if it's a bad thing
and if elected he will come after oil
and gas which
we hope he absolutely will and then
also tweeting just wild quote just
signed an
order to support the workers of delphi
corporation
and make sure we protect the pensions of
all american workers
obama biden failed american workers
and failed the workers of delphi i
always put american workers first
trump is so jealous of barack obama it's
so clear
and for good reason barack obama is able
to coherently express
political ideas he's able to connect
with people in a human way
you don't have to like his drone policy
you don't have to like his position on
uh warrantless surveillance or whatever
else
but trump has much reason to be jealous
of barack obama and i love as a strategy
bringing barack obama
heavily for these last two to three
weeks you're not seeing george w bush
out there
for uh donald trump and in fact from
what we've heard
it's quite plausible that george w bush
is not even voting for donald trump
barack obama will be a big presence over
the next eight days
i think it's great we'll be covering
some of the events live on youtube
twitch and facebook and i am sure that
the triggering will continue for the
next eight days
we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p
here's a caller who thinks trump really
will leave the country if he loses next
week take a listen to this
hey david joe from california hey um
as you know with everything with trump
is protection
and uh i think every time he now has
been saying
oh if i lose i'll leave the country he
actually means it because he knows he's
under several
state investigations especially with the
new york da's office
true and a few other things going on so
i think he knows
i'm gonna lose i better leave the
country because
otherwise i'm won't be able to pardon
myself on state charges
so i'm going to leave the country so
again it's a projection
yeah i actually i i talked to a few
friends over the weekend and they were
saying
the same thing they they they're
thinking trump really will leave the
country
although their thought was you know not
these more cartoonish like he'll go hide
out in russia which i just
don't think that's gonna happen but more
like trump will permanently relocate to
like his
scottish golf course or something like
that
um again i think there are many
countries that would love
to welcome a former u.s president who's
going to criticize
potentially the election system that
gets his opponent elected but we're very
much getting ahead of ourselves
all we have to do now is vote we'll deal
with if
and where trump will go to live later
let's first
take care of business on the bonus show
today
mike pence has five aides including his
chief of staff
tested positive for covid19 number two
grocery stores are preparing for a
second
sort of buying panic as we get into
rapidly climbing cases now in the fall
into winter
and a boston ballot box much like the
one i
used has been set on fire the city
putting out a message saying
if you dropped off your ballot during a
certain range of times
please contact us because it appears as
though some ballots have quite literally
gone up in smoke
all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show get instant access
instant to the bonus show by signing up
at joinpackman.com i look forward to
speaking to you then
and or on tomorrow's show
thanks so much for watching today's full
episode of the show just a reminder
today's
sponsor is blinkist the app that lets
you read or listen
to an entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try blinkist for free
and save 25 off of a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com david pakman
i've also included the link right
underneath this video